Lyrical: Several members of Liquid are very low
and KuroKy getting right-clicked...forced to
pop the Supernova. They're able to jump in
they find a kill onto GH. There's the Ravage
counter-play thought.
GoDz: Oh the roar!
Lyrical: Is it going to be enough? They're able to find it!
SO MUCH DAMAGE. Miracle- goes in as well.
Dominating for him!
GoDz: What a Savage Roar! The Ravage wasn't gonna to be enough
to save that egg. That egg was still going down.
Lyrical: Oh! And the Sunstrike!
GoDz: Miracle-!
Lyrical: Miracle- the magic man does it again!
Desk: OHHHHHHH!!!!
Sheever: And people are cheering Liquid right now!
Merlini: Liquid is definitely back.
ODPixel: Liquid's dominance in just some of
these games really has to just make you
sit back and just go: Wow.
Lyrical: ...At least for now, Vici.J...
Ohhh the big stomp! The combo!
See ya later Vici.J!
There were some heroes there a second ago!
Take him down, but he does still have buy-back.
Merlini: Roshan is almost dead, Miracle- and
MinD_Control trying to take it down. Miracle- will
snag the Cheese
Lyrical: Oh the most sneaky of plays!
They take it. And rOtK, he can't believe it.
Agressif, mad as hell!
But they can't run him down. He eats the Cheese
and runs away. What a player.
off the road with 50 he gets the Sun
hasn't going to go down to the other
great Kabul get out of the road trying
to rise Sam ate some bad link
God if you got him again oh no he's just
constantly got it used inside their
heads click miracle is going to back out
a way Raven really well played announced
they're controlling up that every movie
so he walked away everybody on my way to
be here but they're not going to end up
falling for jumps takes a tree or the
relocated and that's going to miracle a
little bit further announced the change
her fate wants to find earned keeping
him alive he gets the change he gets the
kill 10
trying to go in the show at least for
the moment i'm a couple of my controls
now shown up throughout the table seat
there's the road on the ROC k is already
erased so that there's the damage they
have enough to take him down and then
we're also going to use is going to
follow the fries with my humble man it's
just a monster in the fight another seal
of borough on the miracle they stop the
duel as well kuroki get a rabbit off
there with our cocks turn around the
first fingers after the game in the
midway point out of anyone who looks
just like you have mercy and you can
also prevent a lot of the doing terribly
all really good play there they relocate
out to remember though and it was well
setup because now the rest of liquid is
coming in from the southeast up the
Medusa doesn't go pfft center out as
well connected on 271 it looks like
they're not all drop it super low
because relocate back and away by the
i/o so gonna be five so far as the metro
fear it looks like it should be okay for
the moment is Raven
its lucky individual in there and
they'll take a mile
oh and otherwise any quite find it
pretty close to this we fight it is
getting those 372 the spirit oh my god
that was eh ok that was particularly
good with
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button